[Applause]
we live for this big win I mean yes yes
a triumphant win for such a triumphant
movie chadwick boseman lipid in the
yong-go angela bassett means that the
cast is just so amazing and
Chadwicks speech even though the media
started playing they're trying they're
trying to rush him off was it truly
inspiring yeah let's take a look at it
was one of the best of evening we know
what it's like to be beneath or not
above in that is what we went to work
with every day because we knew not that
we would be around during award season
and that it would make a billion dollars
but we knew that we had something
special
that we wanted to give the world that we
could be full human beings in the roles
that we were playing that we create we
could create a world that exemplified a
world that we wanted to see we knew that
we had something so amazing you know
like I don't want to say this is the
culmination of a great year for the cast
of Black Panther Cassidy because we
still have the Oscars we still have more
Awards but you know representation in
Hollywood
crazy rich Asians and now this it's just
it's just very indicative of where we're
going with movies and it was a fantastic
oh my god there's I mean it's the third
highest grossing movie of all time by
Titanic and Avatar I mean it was funny
because we talked about this the other
day when we were kind of giving out our
predictions who was gonna take home
performance by a cast in a motion
picture and you know obviously the
category is heavy hitters you know you
have a star's born you have black
Klansmen Bohemian Rhapsody but you got
to think of it as the performance by the
cast when I think of for example a star
is born I really only think of like
three characters you know Sam Bradley
and Lady gaga
but when I think of Black Panther I
think of how important each person's
role role was and how it just it was
pivotal to collectively
but I mean just the movie itself the
message the technology the visuals the
music I was a little nervous that
because Black Panther kind of came out
before a lot of the other movies that it
would have lost the momentum but I'm
very very very happy that the Screen
Actors Guild recognizes how important
this movie was and is and like Chadwick
said there was no Black Panther without
after it those are fantastic points also
being that it's a superhero movie okay
so normally you have Batman The Dark
Knight Superman x-men those are movies
that yes they do fantastic at the box
office but really don't garner up
performance accolades for the actors in
these moves because the action that the
CGI but great points because every
single role in that from from the pizza
to to Lateisha to Chadwick just came out
swinging so well deserved
next up the winner for female actor in a
leading role Glenn Close yes she won for
the wife Glenn listen to her speech
truly fantastic I am so proud to be in
this Union I am so proud to receive this
award from my fellow actors and I think
of all of the sitting in the room and I
think of all of you watching on TV all
of you who haven't had the chances that
we've had and I salute you with this I
I'm not surprised with this one she won
the globe she's nominated for an Oscar
for this role of course she also tied
with dog at the Critics Choice Award I
mean this this this was her best work I
will say in my personal opinion and I
just I love a good a good Glenn Close
moment okay she's a fantastic actress
legendary she's up there was a Meryl
Streep I mean I my favorite Glenn Close
is a fatal attraction start cooking the
bunny with Michael Douglas I'll be
having a reunion tonight both of them
were there at the SAG Awards but I will
say though one of the things I love
about her speech and a lot of
and a lot of other speeches tonight is
that why are they there at the SAG
Awards we're just losing stuff here
we're so excited it's because they want
to recognize what sag AFTRA is and they
want to recognize that yes not only are
the actors being being recognized for
their fantastic and stellar roles but
stand-ins people that are extras sag
afterwards just for that - to make sure
that they have a safe and and ethical
work environment so when all these
actors like Glenn Close highlights that
it's like cheerio I'm prepared 100% all
right you guys next category uh rami
malek another one that I am not
surprised with rami malek winning
outstanding performance by a male actor
in a leading role giving an unbelievable
speech of course attributing his statue
to Freddie Mercury here's a little clip
of a speech this just seems
extraordinary to me when I look at those
actors I am nominated with truly I just
never in my wildest dreams thought I
could be in a category with these men
and I'm so proud to be one of your peers
and to be celebrate my peers tonight to
be celebrated by them I mean he first of
all and he's Golden Goal speech was so
moving you know this is for you
beautiful men tonight he's just he's so
effusive and he's so gracious for this
role because he's playing Freddie
Mercury Pasi it's not like he is um he
is inviting a a fictional person Frieda
Mercury was real the pressure what's so
interesting is before he went into this
role he really didn't know the magnitude
of who Freddie Mercury was as an
individual he was familiar with Queen
but you know he didn't really dive into
the world so what I love and why I think
this is so deserving of an award for
Rami is that his prep for this role I
mean he took classes first speech for
dance I mean obviously you can't
choreograph Freddie Mercury but he did
the best that he could and I just you
know wearing the teeth and the the how
his voice whole body match everything -
it's he I I will say when I watched this
movie it was after stars born and I at
first I was like oh my god a star's
bored it's gonna take home all the
awards
and then I watch Bohemian Rhapsody and
I'm like sure it's gotta go to Rami well
we caught up with Romney on the red
carpet who also had some amazing things
to say about his experience take a look
it's been it's been breathtaking I mean
to get a golden globe was one thing you
just you dream about these moments as an
actor as a young man and when they come
to fruition you almost just can't
believe that it's happening so no really
and then to get an Oscar nomination the
other day was it's obviously the
highlight of my career that's something
I will have for the rest of my life and
as a young man to ever think that that
moment was possible I just I thought it
was out of reach and it just proves that
we can achieve our dreams if we put put
the work in it can happen that was what
he just said right there was also an
echoing theme of a lot of people jason
bateman when he gave his speech when he
accept his award for ozark which will
touch out a little bit later said hey
you're one job away from your dream job
if you're not working as much as you
were before it's okay I was there before
after Arrested Development that was him
rubbing mouth talking to nischelle
Turner and I just think it's interesting
that you know we had the Oscars we had
the Golden Globes which celebrates
Hollywood but these are celebrating the
people behind the scenes as well well
you mention the Oscars and I have a
question for you the SAG Awards are kind
of a bellwether for the Oscars now with
Rami taking home the the statue for male
actor in a leading role do you think
he's going to take the Oscar home as
well well just like you i watch the
stars board and we'll human Rhapsody
back-to-back and i think i think it's a
toss-up between bradley cooper and him
he really rami romney's gonna take it I
think Rob Rami kasi Romney had a more
dynamic performance 100 percent everyone
who is watching tweet us at ET now using
the hashtag ET live we want to know your
opinions too and you know who you're
excited for that one and who you think
you know might take home and ask her to
but this ensemble led by Tony Shalhoub
Alex Borstein Marin Hinkle and Michael
vegan as well as our guest actors and
are too often
background actors who work the same
hours with us and share this union with
us many of them I couldn't be luckier to
be a part of this amazing group of
artists so good that was Rachel
Brosnahan during her acceptance speech
at the SAG Awards she received
outstanding performance by a female
actor in a comedy series for her role as
midge in the marvelous mrs. Mazal the
marvelous mrs. Mayes all you guys
tonight just swept everything pretty
much her co-star Tony Shalhoub also
snagged a win for outstanding
performance by a male actor in a comedy
series
he plays midges dad Abe but that's the
only win the show received at the sack
Awards the series even that's not the
only win so I've stopped the series even
took home outstanding performance by an
ensemble in a comedy series when you
know this is this is all within like the
first 10 minutes of the sad marvelous I
could even see it was back to back to
back and so they were nominated they
kind of led the TV nominations with four
of them and they want everything that
they were nominated for obviously the
fourth one is for Alex Borstein who was
nominated alongside Rachael obviously
she didn't take it home but Rachael
still did so it's all within the family
they literally crushed the SAG Award
they rightfully so Delora
it's a great show it's a quick and you
know I think I mean who talked about
this one time cuz everyone was like the
marvelous missus maybe you gotta get in
towards like whatever
no it's okay I have not I've seen the
first episode I have not watched the
rest of it it's in its second season
correct yes okay yeah it's one of the
ones that I'm definitely I have to get
on I just hear something yeah here's why
because not only is it brilliantly
written and the content is just so
fantastic but women breaking a norm and
doing something that a man has normally
dominated back in that time and still
having just autonomy over who she is in
her career in her life it's truly
groundbreaking when people say the
marvelous mrs. Maysles groundbreaking I
normally laugh when they they use the
groundbreaking the word groundbreaking
for things with this it's on point I
love that mic drop for that um okay I
want to go to this is us next because
and I was so sad you you I think you
went to go change or you were in the
bathroom when this one was announced and
my excitement I was literally off the
little couch and screaming for this is
us winning their second SAG Award for
outstanding performance by an ensemble
in a Drama Series I don't know do we
have do we do have a little clip of
their speech hereness and the actor goes
- this is us they win for the second
year in a row it's not it's they say
it's a pleasant surprise it's not a
pleasant surprise but what's really
interesting is that you had a Rachel
Brosnahan who was just seeing sterling
Kate Brown's praises on the red carpet
if she could be in a project with anyone
it would be with him I if I could be in
a project with anybody would be sterling
K Brown - I do believe we have that clip
from the red carpet can we can we show
that you spearheaded this whole
storyline of the big three finding Nicky
what are we gonna find out next you know
we're gonna find out that things aren't
what they seem perhaps you know we took
this whole journey with Jack and we
built him up into this superhero and no
no he's a liar well you know what people
lie and good people lie and and and
here's though here's a weird thing for
you to wrap your brain around which I
kind of haven't quite yet but honest
people sometimes lie there are things
that Jack has done that I support and
there are other things that I do not not
speaking to his brother for that many
years I don't but I also understand men
of that era coming out of war the
difficulties of it that's a very tough
thing to shoulder and you know we don't
walk in Jack's shoes I a little more
than anybody else but even I know that
there was room for him as a human being
as a family member to like extend his
hand to his brother you know I gotta be
up at 5:00 I'm doing I'm doing a really
great scene with a really good friend of
mine a little guest star
yeah I can't tell you really great
singing that was the cast of this is us
on the red carpet with ETS Kelty night I
got enough of them right shake him up
dab you just heard it from Chris Hillman
they have an early call time tomorrow
morning like 6:00 a.m. but they have a
well deserved win that they should be
celebrating tonight I would agree a true
shocker though is female actor in a
supporting role we were all either
shocked or about to cry and we blunt for
a quiet praise plate place it was rated
directed by her husband John Krasinski
and she paid tribute in her acceptance
speech so good the entire experience of
doing this with you has completely
pissed my heart directly you are a
stunning filmmaker I'm so lucky to be
with you and to have done this film with
you thank you for giving me the part you
would have been in major trouble if you
hadn't so you didn't really have an
option but thanks yeah where is my John
tears in his eyes just so proud of his
wife but I feel like both of them were
equally surprised as well as kind of
everyone watching at home too because
she hasn't really been getting a lot of
love this award season she was kind of
snubbed for the Oscars no love for a
quiet place for her role or her role as
Mary Poppins so I think she was just
like I was right oh my god and I will
say she also wins Best Dressed in my
eyes a girl pink sparkly numbered I
don't even know what this was up here
but it was epic paired with those
gorgeous Forevermark diamonds
I mean she's flawless and she even said
on stage she was like she was so
surprised that she said something cute
about like how her like hair is just
like slicked back yeah what was
interesting though - and super super
just super endearing was that when they
announced the the runners in the
category jag was anyone woo before she
even won I mean their love affair and
their love is so real because they're a
team
obviously personally as husband and wife
and then professionally too as you know
working together on the moon
I just where's my daughter Christmas
game we're manifesting Jhansi tweeted
out earlier the night honored to be on
the arm of this double nominee there he
is with the Emily Blunt so perfect so
great and another thing about a quiet
place is it's really quiet so the amount
the amount of talent it takes to be a
compelling actor without using words
right
surely mesmerizing someone else who was
mesmerizing tonight is more her Sheila
Ali taking home a big win for his role
in Green Book I do believe that we have
his acceptance speech mostess paternity
of artists who have the the good fortune
of getting a deal and wrestle with the
human condition and trying to do that
responsibly so so thank you so much on
the red carpet as well he was just so so
engaging he beat out Richard he granted
to me Salome and Sam Elia but all the
red carpet it was interested in what he
told et take a listen
I think they tend to tell people about
it and and it's obviously so to me that
tells me that it's resonating with
people more importantly after the fact
the pose - before walking into the table
that was more Hershel as a third SAG
Award win of course he won the Golden
Globe and the Critics Choice for the
stroll and he's also nominated for the
Oscar again I'm this is one that I'm
gonna confidently say I do believe he
will take home the Oscar I mean Green
books fantastic yeah it's just such a
night back it's hard to get our words
together because parties and glamour and
the Hollywood are gonna go out to our
friends at variety are falling at all
listen to out to our friend marc malkin
he is a senior events and lifestyle
editor add variety he is in the press
room right now Marc what is going on
there's a big party going on it
you probably hear the music it's kind of
insane it's pretty exciting backstage is
kind of this so in a while
informal thing where it's just pictures
and holding up those trophies which are
13 pounds mark I could imagine the
winners who are going back in the press
room are very excited but probably also
very emotional have you seen anyone shed
some tears there's definitely been some
tears shed and there's definitely been
some shaking and like oh my god I won
Sandra Oh whoo I think everyone thought
was going to win I feel like she didn't
know it because she actually came
backstage and you have to sign these
commemorative posters and she's like I
can't even sign my name right now I mean
speaker Sandra Oh her acceptance speech
was it was truly mesmerizing and moving
in the fact that she highlighted Africa
I'll free Woodard and Lena weaith and
Jamie Foxx and when she said that Alfie
would would her told her hey I see you I
know what you're doing you are a woman
of color in this business I I know what
you're going through I feel you I think
that to me was one of the breakout and
standout acceptance speeches of the
night for me what do you think mark I
mean I think it was just such a personal
thing the fact that she remembered when
they said etre what year they said HR
and obviously you know Sandra oh she
really has been representing the
community and every community that's
been marginalized sees themselves in
Sandra oh and she has had white a year I
mean she co-hosted the Golden Globes for
saying you know it's pretty amazing and
she's really one of those people who is
on the carpet and she's humble she has
humility she's not someone who has
turned into a diva maybe she has every
reason to be a diva but she's not turned
into yes preach preaching the gospel
mark so we just talked about Emily Blunt
in John Krasinski's moment when John was
tearing up did you tear up - I did mark
I just tear up when I think about them I
mean it just really you watch them and
it is so real
there is nothing some couple of and
you're like yeah they don't really like
these really like each other they like
hanging out together and the fact that
he just helped her get this kind of mind
block and talk about her Here I am
placing Mary Poppins but she goes and
gets a SAG Award for the movie that our
husband of bro
mark now you're obviously you're
backstage in the press room and can you
give us give our audience a little kind
of backstage glimpse into what what
happens after people come into the press
room like where do they go after so
basically they win their award they come
off stage they come and they sign these
commemorative coasters and SAG Award
posters and then they do like a little
portrait then actually there's someone
backstage who is printing out photos of
them from their win from them being on
stage and they're putting them in frames
and giving it to them then they do a
photo line then they do a bunch of and
they do the interview room and then they
get to go back into the award show so
it's really sort of this machine this
sort of assembly line that's going on
and it's really sweet you have someone
like Zachary Levi we got there early and
he just waited until the rest of the
cast of our business amazing thing to
take the cast photo he wouldn't go on
the photo line by himself then you have
something like Charlie photos with this
Bryce no it's a winner's walk that he
brought his wife on it's so sweet that's
so sue well mark we will actually catch
check back in with you and a little bit
to get more of that backstage glimpse at
the SAG Awards pressroom absolutely now
we're checking with ETS nischelle Turner
who was hanging out with some of the
cast of this is us at the SAG thank I
just love to the conversations that were
had with such care and compassion and
just really did my heart good watching
that's like the reactions that we would
this is such a realistic show with
realistic situations so that people are
actually like heart but about it it's
like I mean Randall's won the election
what happens to the family what's going
on we'll see like upcoming episodes you
will see how this situation changed it
for the good and for the bad least he
got to come back in the bedroom since he
went on the couch anymore we were
worried about Beth and Randall alright
you lady Stefan we're gonna do tonight I
get to the after-party can really done
I'm gonna eat the first thing you're
gonna eat when you take this dress up
everything congratulations y'all alright
have a good one you look beautiful
ladies as they should get some in-n-out
burger if you want that was et's
Michelle Turner a backstage with some of
the cast of this is us big night for
them celebrating their outstanding
performance by an ensemble in a Drama
Series win congratulations to all of the
winners at the SAG Awards we here at eat
cielab we're gonna break down the
winners and the snubs the surprise is
the more bat here's the fashion all of
it all of it guy stayed with the
straight Morici live when we come back
[Music]